look alive everyone because we've got a
lunchtime poll do you like a vin diesel
be elemental magic see flaming swords or
D Egret from Game of Thrones if your
answer is all of the above then we've
got the perfect weekend movie for you if
you've watched a trailer for the last
witch hunter the actual movie is exactly
what you think it is the story follows a
man named Calder played by diesel who
has been hunting practitioners of the
dark arts ever since he was cursed with
immortality by the evil witch queen that
was about eight hundred years ago and if
you couldn't tell from the title he is
an army of one calder known among
witches as the weapon has spent
centuries seeking out those who would
use magic on humans the ultimate tag now
its present day and the presumed dead
witch queen who cursed him is trying to
come back and kill everyone called her
house stopper it would help from Elijah
Frodo wood and rose you know nothing Jon
Snow Leslie he stands a fighting chance
you want to quit no I want to raise if
all this sounds a little you know
ridiculous well of course it is but fear
not the last witch hunter is actually a
really good time yes the dialogue is
pretty basic and there is a place
literally called which prison but seeing
Vin Diesel slash and burn a bunch of
Nouveau baroque wishes his just damn fun
oh and did we mention his sword lights
on fire look there's nothing
earth-shattering about the last witch
hunter but if you can embrace the fact
that a bunch of people dressed to attend
a dinner party at Stevie mixes house are
casting spells and down
New York City it might be the best dumb
time you have it the movies always yeah
you're not qualified for what happens
next